Vivimos en un mundo increíblemente interconectado
donde la proliferación de las redes sociales
es por supuesto un recurso fantástico para promover el cambio social,
pero que también nos ha vuelto cada vez más sensibles
a cosas desde las quejas de menos importancia: "Mi tren se retrasa"
hasta las graves injusticias
cómo la guerra, los genocidios y los ataques terroristas.
Nuestra respuesta predeterminada es reaccionar ante cualquier tipo de agravio
por Twitter y Facebook, usando hashtags
que muestren a otros que nosotros también hemos reaccionado.
Reaccionar de esta forma, en masa, se transforma en un problema
porque a veces esto significa que en realidad no reaccionamos en absoluto,
no en el sentido de que realmente hacemos algo.
Podría hacernos sentirnos mejor,
porque contribuimos a apoyar a los directamente afectados
pero en realidad esto no cambia nada.
Y es más, a veces puede silenciar las voces
de las personas directamente afectadas por la injusticia,
cuyas necesidades deben de ser escuchadas.
También es preocupante la tendencia creada
por algunas reacciones a esas injusticias de levantar aún más muros,
por gente que se apresura hacer acusaciones en seguida
con la esperanza de proporcionar soluciones fáciles a problemas complejos.
Un periódico británico incluyó este titular al publicar mi carta:
"Estudiante de Oxford lanza una campaña en línea para avergonzar al atacante".
Pero la campaña nunca tuvo la intención de avergonzar a nadie.
Quería dejar que la gente hablara y que los demás escuchen.
Los trolls de Twitter se apresuraron a provocar aún más injusticias,
haciendo comentarios sobre la etnia o la clase social de mi agresor
para reforzar sus propios prejuicios.
Algunos incluso me acusaron de fingir todo el asunto
para impulsar, y cito,
mi "agenda feminista andrófoba".
Lo sé.
Como si fuera a decir, "¡Hola chicos! Lo siento, no puedo acudir,
estoy ocupada tratando de odiar a todos los hombres
antes de llegar a cumplir los 30".
Estoy casi segura
de que estas personas no dirían esto en persona.
Pero ya sea que está detrás de una pantalla,
en la comodidad de su propia casa o en las redes sociales,
la gente olvida de que lo que escribe se vuelve público
y otras personas lo leerán y les afectarán.
De vuelta a mi idea de volver a tomar el metro,
otra de mis preocupaciones frente a este ruido que nace
de nuestras respuestas en línea a la injusticia
es que fácilmente puede definirnos como la parte afectada,
que puede llevar a causar una sensación de derrota,
a una barrera mental
que bloquea cualquier oportunidad para la positividad y el cambio
después de una situación negativa.
Un par de meses antes del inicio de la campaña
o del hecho que me pasó,
fui a un evento TEDx en Oxford y vi hablar a Zelda la Grange,
la ex secretaria personal de Nelson Mandela.
Una de las historias que contó realmente me llamó la atención.
Habló de cuando Mandela fue llevado a los tribunales
por la Unión Sudafricana de Rugby
después de encargar una investigación sobre asuntos deportivos.
Se acercó en el tribunal a los abogados de la Unión Africana de Rugby del Sur,
les dió la mano y conversaron, cada uno en su propio idioma.
Y Zelda quería protestar,
diciendo que no tenían derecho a su respeto
después de esta injusticia que le habían causado.
Él se volvió hacia ella y le dijo:
"Nunca se debe permitir al enemigo que decida los motivos de la batalla".
Al escuchar estas palabras,
realmente no sabía que eran tan importantes,
pero sentí que lo eran y las apunté en un cuaderno que llevaba.
He pensado mucho en esta frase desde entonces.
La venganza, o la expresión del odio
hacia los que nos han hecho injusticias
puede parecer un instinto humano frente al mal,
pero tenemos que romper este círculo
si aspiramos a transformar hechos negativos injustos
en un cambio social positivo.
Hacer lo contrario
significa dejar que el enemigo determine el campo de batalla,
crea un arma de doble filo
donde los que hemos sufrido somos los afectados
que nos enfrentamos a ellos, los agresores.
Y al igual que volvimos a nuestro metro,
no podemos dejar que nuestras plataformas para la interconectividad y la comunidad
sean lugares que aceptan la derrota.
Pero no quiero desanimar la respuesta de las redes sociales,
porque debo el desarrollo de la campaña #NotGuilty
casi en su totalidad a las redes sociales.
Pero sí quiero fomentar un enfoque más atento
acerca de la forma en que las usamos para responder a la injusticia.
Creo que para empezar hay que preguntarnos dos cosas.
Primera: ¿Por qué siento esta injusticia?
En mi caso, hubo varias respuestas.
Alguien me hirió; a mí y a los que quiero,
bajo el supuesto de que no tendría que rendir cuentas
o reconocer el daño que había causado.
No solo eso, sino que miles de personas que sufren cada día
un abuso sexual, a menudo en silencio, siguen siendo afectadas por un problema
al que no damos la misma cobertura que otras cuestiones
y en el cuyo caso todavía muchas personas culpan a las víctimas.
Pregúntense, al admitir estos motivos: ¿podríamos revertirlos?
Con nosotros, obligaba mi atacante a rendir cuentas, y a muchos otros.
Se les llamó la atención sobre lo que habían causado.
Se estaba dando cobertura a la cuestión del abuso sexual,
abriendo la discusión entre amigos, familias, en los medios
que habían estado cerrados por mucho tiempo,
insistiendo en la inocencia de las víctimas por lo sucedido.
Todavía hay un largo camino para solucionar este problema por completo.
Pero podemos usar de ese modo las redes sociales,
como una herramienta activa para la justicia social,
para educar, para fomentar diálogos,
para que los que están en posiciones de autoridad sean conscientes de una cuestión
escuchando a las personas directamente afectadas.
Porque a veces estas preguntas no tienen respuestas fáciles.
De hecho, rara vez la tienen.
Pero esto no quiere decir que no podemos ofrecer una respuesta prudente.
En situaciones donde es imposible no pensar
en cómo revertir este sentimiento de injusticia,
todavía se puede pensar
tal vez no lo que puedes hacer sino en lo que puedes dejar de hacer.
Puedes dejar de construir más muros
y luchar contra la injusticia con más prejuicios y más odio.
Puedes dejar de levantar la voz por encima de los afectados por una injusticia
y no se puede reaccionar ante la injusticia
para olvidarse de ella al día siguiente solo porque Twitter ha seguido adelante.
A veces, irónicamente, no reaccionar en seguida
es la mejor acción inmediata que podemos tomar
porque podríamos estar enfadados, molestos y motivados por la injusticia,
pero consideremos nuestras respuestas.
Hagamos que la gente rinda cuentas sin degradarnos avivando una cultura
que se nutre de la vergüenza y la injusticia.
Recordemos esta diferencia,
tan a menudo olvidada por los internautas,
entre la crítica y el insulto.
No olviden pensar antes de hablar,
solo porque tenemos una pantalla delante de nosotros.
Y cuando hacemos ruido en las redes sociales,
no dejemos que se ahoguen las necesidades de los afectados,
sino que se amplifiquen sus voces,
para que el Internet se convierta en un lugar donde no seas la excepción
si hablas acerca de algo que realmente te ha sucedido.
Todos estos enfoques atentos frente a la injusticia
evocan la razón de ser y la base sobre cual se construyó el Internet:
la de comunicarse, transmitir, conectar,
todos términos que implican unir a la gente no separarla.
Porque si buscan la palabra "justicia" en el diccionario,
antes de "castigo",
"administración de la ley" o "autoridad judicial"
se define
como "Respetar lo que es correcto".
Y creo que hay algunas cosas más "correctas" en este mundo
que acercan a las personas, que los sindicatos.
Y si permitimos que los medios sociales lo hagan,
entonces ofrecerán una forma muy potente de la justicia.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)